[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai eu 23 ans ma mère m'a fait un
cadeau inhabituel elle m'a offert un
grand bac dans lesquels se trouvaient
des souvenirs d'enfance on s'est mis à
fouiller dans le bac en sang j'ai trouvé
des bibelots
des recalages
du linge de bébé
est
incarnée
dans ce carnet là se trouver des
réponses à des questions pour me décrire
mon activité préférée
ma couleur préférée
move
il ma plus grande peur
me tromper
j'avais 6 ans
à peu près au même moment j'ai un vif
souvenir d'avoir vu dans mon agenda ce
qu'on appela un rouge vous savez le
système vert jaune rouge pour dire aux
parents comment s'est passée la journée
je revois encore là ma tête la personne
qui est assise devant moi à son pupitre
se retourner j'avais beach non on n'a
pas le droit parler mais l'enseignante
nous a quand même mis un rouge la
catastrophe pour moi probablement mon
premier souvenir
d'évaluation
en avez vous des souvenirs d'évaluation
qui vous ont marqué à main levée des
erreurs quand même voir les horreurs qui
vous avez fiat qui vous ont semblé
catastrophique
les droits à l'erreur pourtant ça fait
partie du processus de développement
des recherches sur l'intelligence mené
par carol dweik ont montré que si on dit
à un enfant après avoir réalisé un stage
qui est intelligent donc c'est un peu
lui dire i performant mais il va avoir
tendance à choisir une tâche plus facile
par la suite comme pour maintenir son
statut de performant
si on le récompense plutôt sont le fil
site pour les efforts qu'ils ont investi
dans la page qui a mené à sa réussite
mais il va avoir tendance à choisir une
tâche plus difficile et donc de
contribuer à son développement
on fait un constat similaire dans les
organisations il ya des chercheurs qui
rapporte que face aux pressions la
performance et la concurrence ça
encourage les organisations à utiliser
des stratégies
qu'utilisent déjà plutôt qu'en essayer
de nouvelles
donc c'est un frein à la créativité à la
prise de risque et ultima à l'innovation
ce que je vous parle ce soir c'est une
tension entre apprentissage
e-performance où je devrais plutôt dire
de négociation parce que les deux
peuvent cohabiter ensemble mais ce n'est
pas toujours facile
parce que d'un côté on à
l'apprentissage que j'associe au
processus un processus dans lequel on se
donne le droit d'expérimenter de tester
des choses de porter un regard critique
sur nos actions
un apprentissage peu dans le sens
d'acquérir plein de connaissances mais
vraiment un processus de développement
de l'autre côté on a la performance le
plus souvent associé à un résultat une
réussite probablement à court terme un
résultat fort probablement aussi mesuré
par des indicateurs quantitatifs
une note un bulletin un chiffre
d'affaires un nombre de minutes passées
avec un usager pour répondre à son
besoin avant de passer au prochain
un nombre de clients servis dans un
restaurant
l'efficacité l'efficience
la performance
cette négociation là entre apprentissage
et performance j'ai lu observé dans
plusieurs contextes professionnels le
premier c'est dans les cales de ma thèse
dans une organisation qui gère 10
logement social public
cette organisation leur chercher à
mobiliser les locataires à favoriser
leur engagement
favoriser leur prise de pouvoir mais en
tant qu'organisation public b devait
aussi rendre des comptes et les
gestionnaires les employés étaient
engagés atteindre des résultats
rapidement parce qu'il voulait que le
projet fonctionne
mais à vouloir atteindre des résultats
rapidement mais ça pouvait faire en
sorte finalement mais qui avait moins de
temps pour l'apprentissage qui prenaient
moins de temps pour consulter les
locataires alors qu'il voulait justement
leur donner plus de pouvoirs
le deuxième contexte c'est dans le cadre
d'un mandat de formation avec des
professionnels d'expérience on invitait
ses professionnels là à tester des
choses à se placer un peu sur
d'apprentissage avec leur clientèle et
c'est tout posé la question de mais
comment je peux même dans cette posture
là alors que je dois maintenir macri tu
n'as crédibilité parlons auprès de ces
personnes qui ont aussi des attentes de
résultats et de performances
le troisième contexte en milieu
universitaire dans le cadre d'une
recherche je rencontre des personnes
étudiante qui me parle de commander fois
c'est difficile de prendre parole parce
qu'ils ont peur de poser des questions
street parce qu'ils ont peur de pas
avoir la bonne réponse puis finalement
ben c'est un frein aussi alors apprendre
sage
cette culture de performance là elle est
omniprésente
je vais faire le test avec vous
normalement on a un échantillon de 100
personnes si si je vous demande à mes le
vix qui dans les dernières semaines ont
ressenti une pression performance
dans votre travail
dans vos études votre formation
peut-être
dans votre vie personnelle comme
partenaire comme parra
c'est omniprésent
et pour vous donner un exemple très
concret en faire
cerny présent même dans des lieux où
est-ce qu'on penserait pouvoir y
échapper je vous donne un exemple
concret j'ai fait ma formation en
psychologie ce que le gic est un domaine
contingenté parce qu'on espère pouvoir
atteindre les docteurs et je me souviens
encore des premières journées au bac à
l'arrière ou est ce qu'une personne
enseignante nous avait demandé qu' ici
dans la salle souhaite devenir
psychologue évidemment on a à peu près
tous et toutes le vit la main sur une
salle de 70 80 personnes dont nous dire
il ya la paix huîtres parmi vous qui
allez rentrer ou d'acteurs
bonjour l'anxiété de performance
pouvez vous imaginer comment c'est
difficile après de se sortir de cette
posture
cet exemple que je vous partage quelques
années plus tard et c'est comme ça et
des gens qui travaillent fort pour
éviter de véhiculer ses messages
mais ça reste pour moi une illustration
vraiment frappante
il y en a d'autres pour avoir côtoyé des
personnes parce que le gie dans d'autres
universités je peux vous dire que j'ai
entendu des histoires d'horreur
des histoires de personnes qui vont
modifier les notes de cours avant de les
prêter un collègue
pour éviter que cette personne a été
meilleure note qu'elle
les personnes qui m'ont arraché des
pages dans des ouvrages de référence
pour éviter que ça soit accessible
tout ça en psychologie
dans un domaine
pour aider les autres il ya quelque
chose
qui marche pas
donc c'est difficile de se sortir de
cette posture de performance là
puis moi même devant vous aujourd'hui
vais je suis aussi
dans une posture est des performances
face à ce constat là on fait quoi
mais première des choses se regardent et
se questionner comme société puis oser
critiquer la question que je pose ce
soir c'est ça ça wright ou
elly où la limite à toujours vouloir se
dépasser à dépasser les autres pour se
démarquer
quand la performance et évaluées selon
des critères
universels qui est l'espace on a pour
les personnes qui rentrent pas dans le
moule la majorité pour les personnes
euros explique par exemple quand la
performance nous demande d'aller
toujours plus vit plus vieux plus vieux
pull bien plus loin
may et où l'espace pour prendre le temps
d'apprendre
quand la performance
égale une seule bonne réponse
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait il y en eu
plusieurs bonnes réponses qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand les solutions qu'on
cherche nous demande de sortir des silos
disciplinaire et s'adapter au contexte
est ce que ça veut dire que je souhaite
que demain matin on élimine la
performance complètement mais pas du
tout je me verrais très mal être dans
une équipe j'apprends beaucoup de choses
mais qui accomplit jamais rien
je verrais mal aussi une entreprise
publique à qui on manque jamais de
comptes à rendre sur la qualité de ses
services
alors qu'elle utilise des fonds publics
c'est nécessaire donc si on peut pas
éliminer la performance on fait quoi
mais il faut se doter des espaces où
est-ce qu'on propre recette est il des
espaces où est-ce qu'on peut réfléchir
ensemble est-ce qu'on peut analyser nos
actions et apprendre à faire autrement
si oui penser une minute est ce que vous
voyez vous des façons de faire dans vos
milieux pour vous d'été de ces espaces
parce qu'on se rend compte que
curieusement c'est quand on a ride un
fouloir performer à tout prix et qu'on
se place dans une posture
d'apprentissage
qu on performe
ça va nous prendre ces espaces le si on
veut non seulement s'adapter à un monde
qui change de plus en plus rapidement
mais le transformer nous mène vers un
monde plus juste et plus inclusif ça
nous prend ces espaces là pour apprendre
si on veut faire autrement et si on veut
changer les paradigmes
et par changer de paradigme je veux dire
aussi de repenser le sens de la
performance et comment on la mesure
ici la performance n'était pas la
croissance à tout prix mais la capacité
à ralentir pour sauver notre planète
ici la performance était d'être capable
de prendre soin des autres et soi-même
en bienveillance et en humanité
et si la performance
c'était
d'avoir un impact durable il pose
sur le monde qui nous entoure
au-delà des chiffres
c'est la question que je vous pose ce
soir et c'est la question que je nous
invite à nous poser collectivement
et personnellement mais l'apprentissage
c'est quelque chose que je porte au
quotidien dans ma vie personnelle comme
ma vie professionnelle l'apprentissage
un objet tatoué sur la peau
littéralement
et si vous me demandiez ce soir d'écrire
dans un nouveau carnet c'est quoi la
chose dont j'ai le plus pas mais
aujourd'hui je vous aurais peur c'est de
me tromper non aujourd'hui la chose dont
j'avais plupart c'est d'arrêter un jour
à prendre
[Applaudissements]